monsieur seck bonsoir bonsoir vous aimez
les arts martiaux vous êtes un adepte
des arts martiaux à ce que c'est la plus
dure bataille de votre vie j'attendrai
de mener pour la survie du npd non non
pas du tout j'ai vécu plus ou des temps
plus difficiles dans ma vie maintenant
c'est un temps difficile pour les gens
que je rencontre est ce que je fais
c'est vraiment de les aider de proposer
des politiques pour pour aider les gens
qui font face des grands défis dans leur
vie mais quand même le npd dans une
situation délicate il vous reste
quatorze circonscriptions au québec et
on a vu depuis quelques jours tous les
autres chefs vont dans vos
circonscriptions
essayez de vous les enlevez comment vous
allez répondre à ces assauts donc on
répond parce que les conservateurs et
les libéraux ils ont toujours prioriser
les plus riches dans chaque décision
qu'il prend il prend des décisions qui
aide les multinationales les grands
compagnie au lieu d'aider monsieur
madame tout le monde
on peut regarder leurs bilans mais sur
trudeau a au lieu de réduire les coupes
les médicaments et l'a écouté les
lobbies des grandes compagnies
pharmaceutiques qui l'ont rencontré plus
de 600 fois
donc au lieu de réduire les coûts pour
les services cellulaires
il a rencontré les lobbyistes encore des
grands compagnie télécommunications et
il a continué de laisser ce qu'ils vont
faire
je vis dans un quartier où il ya
normalement beaucoup de sympathisants du
npd puis à quelqu'un qui ce matin un
pauvre elle me disait le problème que
j'ai c'est que je vois pas la différence
beaucoup des fois entre le npd ou les
verts qu'est ce qui va faire que je vais
voter
qu'est ce qui vous distingue donc on
partage beaucoup avec les biens saisis
c'est clair comme l'argent ce climat t
que l'effet qu'il faut prendre des
décisions audacieuses pour s'attaquer la
crise climatique
je pense que notre plan et les plus
audacieux mais les grandes et france
culture de la chute les verts oui oui
bien sûr et ça c'est pourquoi on a
cherché on a recruté des vedettes des
grands leaders environnementaux comme
hugo latulippe et rex
mais les grands différents sites c'est
ça on ne veut pas jamais laisse tomber
les travailleurs et travailleuses
on a eu une position solide sur les
droits des femmes d'avoir un avortement
on est plus adroit et on veut augmenter
accès aux services d'avortement
on est aussi un très clair position sur
les doigts d imiter lgd vécu ce qui
n'est pas tellement claire avec les
verts notre plan c'est vraiment le plus
complet on veut s'attaquer les
inégalités sociales et l'environnement
et la crise climatique et pourquoi
quelqu'un comme monsieur nantel décidé
de quitter votre navire pour aller vers
les verts
vous devez poser la question en
missionnant talent mais on a recruté
quelqu'un paie ferland qui est un plus
grand environnementalistes on a recruté
les gens comme hugo latulippe ou si
beaucoup beaucoup plus grands on veut
remonter l'isq l'homme que vous avez
parlé donc ce qu'on propose c'est
vraiment un plan qui est le plus complet
on sait ça c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui on
a parlé des référents on a dit que notre
plan s'attaque les inégalités sociales
des perfidies fiscaux le logement les
soins de santé et aussi la crise
climatique
vous avez depuis quelques jours voulu
séduire les québécois en disant il faut
donner plus d'oxygène au québec plus de
pouvoir vous avez fait un document que
pour le québec ce que n'avait pas fait
monsieur walker la dernière fois pour le
pipeline vous dit le québec aurait le
droit de dire non un pipeline le québec
aurait le dernier mot
même chose pour la colombie-britannique
même chose pour toutes les provinces ce
qu'on peut dire si on a un politique il
unique unique est séparée pour le québec
parce que le québec est unique on est
fier de ça on veut partager ça on pense
que cette fierté qu'on a une nation
comme de québec qui a une culture une
identité unique et on veut le défendre
et donc on peut dire ça pour toutes les
autres provinces et territoires
un gouvernement néo-démocrate jamais
imposer un projet sur les autres
provinces
ok si donc le québec dit non un pipeline
même si le gouvernement fédéral qui
aurait le droit de l'imposer vous êtes
jeunes eux l'imposerait jamais et je ne
vais jamais appuyer un gouvernement
minoritaire libéral qui l'imposeraient
ce qu'on a dit c'est exactement ce qu'on
aime
jamais un projet parce qu'on pense il
faut avoir
l'acceptabilité sociale l'incité vous
avez entendu l'appel de monsieur legault
la semaine dernière ça d'ailleurs pris
beaucoup de place dans le débat de cette
première semaine de campagne électorale
quelle est votre position qu'à vous êtes
contre bien sûr la loi vt 1 et me
demande je suis contre un politique une
loi qui divise la population
moi toute ma vie j'ai toujours essayé de
rassembler les gens et les lois qui
discriminent ce n'est pas un bon lois
les lois de droit rassembler les gens
mais comme j'ai dit je n'ai pas
enseignée par exemple au québec vous et
c'est bizarre ça mais je reconnais le
compétences du québec de légiférer ce
que je dis il ya plusieurs enjeux où on
peut travailler ensemble je sais que les
québécois sont là juste avant
sensibiliser je sais que vous avez passé
donc vous ne porteriez jamais cette
cause là devant les tribunaux jamais
vous ne devriez donc vous dites oui à
monsieur legault je vais jamais
m'occuper de ça devant les tribunaux
comme le gouvernement fédéral comme j'ai
dit oui exactement un jeu je reconnais
la compétence du gouvernement
québec dans ce matière ce dossier je
suis tellement content remercier vidéo
mais ce que je veux dire aux québécois
c'est je suis prêt de travail de mai
mais au fort où on est rassemblé ça
c'est pour s'attaquer la crise
climatique
aussi pour mettre plus des financements
pour les logements abordables et pour
les soins de santé
dernière chance sur la loi 21 ce que
vous croyez qu'elle va passer le test
des tribunaux ou qu'elle va être
forcément réécrite à cause des juges de
décisions de court ça c'est une décision
que les juges on comprend des
souffrances passées je pense qu'il doit
être une séparation entre les politiques
et les décisions génétique
moi j'ai pas eu le jdd a dit ma position
personnelle mais dans la cour de justice
ils vont décider à mon sens une seconde
vous dites pour des raisons évidentes là
vous vous êtes pointe et quand je porte
un signe religieux
est ce que vous croyez que c'est un
handicap dans certaines régions où vous
allez faire campagne d'avoir un signe
religieux au canada en 2010
je peux dire que oui dans ma vie j'ai
vécu des difficultés des défis mais
c'est pas différent pour les autres
c'est la même chose pour les femmes les
collègues avec lesquels je travaille ils
me disent que souvent ils font face des
berquière cause les jambes j'ai
rencontré les j'ai rencontré des gens
qui font face tu perds hier à cause de
la sexualité
donc je reconnais cette réalité qui
existe dans la société qui à cause de la
paire ans à cause de l'âge en cause de
l'identité de quelqu'un ils font partie
derrière mais ça c'est pourquoi je suis
fier de défendre l'identité de chacun
l'identité du québec parce que je sais
qu'il y a des bergues et c'est difficile
d'être fiers de notre identité et
comprenez vous cette méfiance là que
beaucoup de québécois ont vis-à-vis
compte tenu du passé de la du poids de
la religion québec
comprenez vous cette méfiance là que des
québécois ont vis-à-vis le religieux et
donc des signes religieux
oui exactement il y as mais je suis
quelqu'un qui croit fermement dans la
séparation entre l'église l'état ça
c'est pourquoi je suis dans mes
croyances personnelles et comme chef du
parti néo-démocrate pour l'avortement
pour le mariage même sac je suis pour
les droits de la personne sans faute
sans doute donc je suis là je veux
revenir à certains de vos engagements de
l'imiter oui oui bien sur le coup
exactement des cellulaires au canada
vous de tout temps aussi le npd veut
limiter les taux d'intérêt sur les
cartes de crédit des choses qui touchent
les gens oui bon c'est une chose le dire
le promettre comment faire pour le faire
oui bien sûr donc on allait pouvoir
c'est complètement dans la juridiction
fédérale de légiférer de régler tout ça
donc ce qu'on va faire on a le courage
d'agir
donc la différence entre moi et
quelqu'un comme monsieur trudeau les
grand complet télécommunications en 575
fois des lobes les rencontres lobbyistes
avec le gouvernement libéraux et ils ont
continué de laisser les complices d'un
des télécommunications décharger
les canadiens canadien le plus haut prix
pour les services cellulaires à travers
le monde
on paie le plus cher donc on veut
changer ça avec les règlements on peut
faire ça avec on va imposer un prix fixe
est limité pour comment ils combien peu
chargé et deuxièmement on va imposer
leurs règlements d'avoir des services et
dîna des datas de données sans limite et
sur scène
est-ce que vous souhaitez l'élection
d'un gouvernement minoritaire moi je
veux devenir premier ministre parce que
je vais aider du monde
je me bats pour les gens et je suis là
pour faire ça s'il y avait un
gouvernement minoritaire
est-ce que vous préféreriez un
gouvernement rouge ou bleu donc j'ai
déjà dit à cause de mes croyances pour
les toits des femmes les droits de qui
militent et le cdbq pour la crise
climatique je ne peux pas non aucune
façon on travaille avec les
conservateurs quand j'ai dit ça maxime
bernier sera du débat et en anglais et
en français organisé par la commission
vos réactions vous aviez dit vous étiez
quand votre savon oui je suis contre ça
je pense qu' il ne doit pas donner un
plateforme faut quelqu'un pour donner
ses messages et indivisible
donc je pense que c'est c'est pas
acceptable de donner un plafonnement
quelqu'un comme ça donc est ce que vous
vous remettez en question votre présence
non je serai là parce que je me barre
contre les commentaires n
donc vous serez là qui il sera là vous
serez à côté de lui donc je vais je vais
être là parce que je vais me battre
contre les discours henin d'accord mais
vous auriez préféré qu'il n'y soit pas
mais c'est comme ça pour la commission
c'est la décision était fait la décision
c'est la décision de l'école comme un
cerf au débat des chefs dont il a pris
la décision
est-ce que vous aurez il reste dix
secondes des candidats dans toutes les
circonscriptions gens manquent encore
dans région de québec introduisant mans
oui on est presque là on a maintenant
atteindre 308 donc on va être là très
bien tu saignes bonne fait campagne
merci beaucoup au revoir mais c'est